ridley what made you think of christian
to portray moses a cup of tea five years
ago yes well a cup of tea yeah very
english very good boys no wood binds no
wood no timber
and fundamentally saying why haven't we
worked together before let's find
something and typically british we never
talk to each other again for another
five years
but i received a script from peter
chernin
with moses and um as i was reading it
it started to click and that's the way
my brain was i'm going geez this is
christian
so by the time i get through it i'm
stunned by what i don't know about moses
but i figured this i'm gonna do it and
the guy that's got to do this is this
man
that's how it happened it's all
intuition there's no science it's gut i
function on god
and christian what's the biggest
challenge in taking on such an iconic
figure just that you know that he's that
he's so
known
and he's so personally
loved and so important to so many people
and um
and people have very very strong
opinions about exactly how he should be
played and i would talk to many people
about that and they would tell me that
they said christian you have to play him
this way and then i speak with somebody
else they would say something completely
different but i have to play him that
way as well and so you have to realize
right that's an enormous pressure but
that's a wonderful kind of a pressure
because it means that it's it's it's a
vital story it's a resonant story and
then i i i get guided by rid and by
steve's alien script and we forge our
own
uh way of of portraying this character
who is a
far more complex character
than i had ever begun to realize
how so
um
the traditional portrayals of him and
the sort of sunday school idea is one
which is quite simple you know i mean
wonderful achievements um liberator law
giver etc but uh the passages that i was
unfamiliar with and i read from
beginning to end um were that he fought
and he fought an awful lot with god he
wrestled with god literally the
definition of israelite um he didn't
want to be his representative um
he was living in very violent times he
was very conflicted himself about who he
was who his own identity was
he was an eternally intriguing character
um possibly the most i've ever come
across
and ridley what triggered your interest
in crafting your version of the exodus
what's my your version
um
well my version
very much of course would be that i
looked at the original version and
versions of other biblical epics
and
they were kind of very exalted and
elevated
by very great filmmakers and great stars
at that particular time and i wanted to
put it back
into the realms of reality making the
whole all the characters real
and i'd once seen the remains of ramsey
so i know he was real he's not a fantasy
he's absolutely real lies in the state
with his coffin is open you can see his
skin his bone structure and his hair so
i know he absolutely existed so i wanted
to comment it from that direction
and in both of your opinions what is
moses's defining characteristic
oh
man i to me i'm i'm too far
in my portrayal you know it's like when
you can't see the wood for the trees you
know um uh to define him with one word
because to me his very nature was the
fact that he was so complex and he was
so very very human you know this was not
a oh you know the other person was
talking about super superheroes he's not
a two-dimensional character in any way
whatsoever he's very much representing
almost every human emotion that you can
possibly have um he has that uh
throughout the torah
so i would find it impossible to find
one word or at least i would have to
take
much longer than a couple of minutes to
figure it out
elsa you've got you've got a guy who's
brought up to with status quo
tennis court being you have a slave
population that is a free labor for
egypt and it's
and all its productivity and its success
and they become
status quo
and at what moment if you're half
intelligent and you have
of any human feelings whatsoever do you
gradually adjust to that idea
therefore i think it's his conscience
that built up
particularly when it was identified that
in fact he was hebrew then he went away
and then he had that period where he sat
thinking about that
and i've always thought that the idea of
the boy malak could easily be perceived
as his conscience on the mountain at
that moment which ignited him to get up
and go back to return to egypt
you